we've gotten our first look into the
first few days of the Trump
administration day-to-day and it is
really really bad the Trump
administration is in disarray Donald
Trump is reportedly demoralized because
he knows millions of people are
questioning the legitimacy of his
presidency
apparently he's constantly just watching
TV and super focused on tweeting instant
responses in many cases to stuff he sees
on TV instead of doing presidential
stuff it's like there's a little kid in
the White House here is a quote from a
Washington Post article about this from
a couple of days ago many critics
thought Spicer referring to Sean Spicer
went too far and compromised his
integrity but in Trump's mind
Spicer's attack on the news media was
not forceful enough the president was
also bothered that the spokesman read at
times haltingly from a printed statement
so Trump not happy with Sean Spicer's
public apologia four completely debunked
lies from Donald Trump also from the
Washington Post article Trump has been
resentful even furious at what he views
as the media's failure to reflect the
magnitude of his achievements and he
feels demoralized that the public's
perception of his presidency so far does
not necessarily align with his own sense
of accomplishment then there's a salon
expose about Trump's reported fixation
or addiction to watching TV Mike Allen
and Jim Vander I of Axios said that
listen Trump doesn't read books and he
avoids reports that are really long that
he considers to be too long he doesn't
use computers he rarely uses a phone for
anything but calls even those infamous
tweets from Trump are usually dictated
someone and submitted by others but the
TV watching aspect is starting to
concern some aides here's a quote from
the Axio story most mornings Trump
flicks on the TV and watches Morning Joe
often for long periods of time sometimes
interrupted with texts to the hosts or
panelists after the 6 a.m. hour of Joe
he's often onto Fox and Friends by 7:00
a.m. with a little CNN before after he
also catches the sunday shows especially
Meet the Press the shows as he calls
them often provoke his tweets the day of
our interview with him
all of his tweet topics were discussed
during the first two hours of Morning
Joe
this is having an impact a negative one
and on Saturday when Trump saw that TV
networks were talking about his of tepid
inauguration turnout compared to
President Obama's impressive
inauguration turnout in 2009 he became
so furious and I guess his staff Pat
were trying to tell him to just ignore
stuff and not start tweeting and they
could not convince him not to tweet and
that's when Trump started tweeting about
it it's just so concerning that he's
watching TV around the clock I mean I
get it the guy's a narcissist and he's
getting a lot of validation because
they're covering him all the time yeah
but when you combine narcissism with
just being lazy I mean that's a
dangerous combination well everything we
suspected about Trump in terms of his
lack of intellectual curiosity never
reading narcissism etc everything we saw
before election today is now coming true
and being verified day after day in the
early days of his presidency he's
insecure
he's spin skinned he's concerned with
optics rather than governance he's not
knowledgeable he can't focus on anything
when it comes to reading you basically
have a posse of low information grifters
running the country which is exactly
what we expected this is the first week
can you imagine the insanity that will
take place and the damage that will be
done in the four years to come